[Music]
hey you guys what's going on happy
tuesday yeah so there are people here
right nobody's talking usually if
somebody comes on it goes first
nobody needs it
how am i supposed to know anybody
they're coming here okay that's good
unless unless my weird chat thing isn't
working i don't really know you don't
have any chat either okay yeah i have
chat all right no i mean
yeah they're talking oh okay said what's
up
oh i'm not seeing it on mine i wonder
why i see it i started having trouble
yesterday there it goes okay i just
needed to like re all right yeah okay so
that's all
she's sleeping no she now she's looking
at me oh okay well she was sleeping you
probably woke her up yeah in the door
yeah
and she's like another show why are you
talking to those lights stop talking to
them they're talking like she's yawning
oh
all right
yeah okay they're coming in it's all
right pokey all right so someone call
gone baby gone
uh we think louie sent me i'm pretty
sure louis dennis it was a long time ago
and as i said if you did send us movies
a long time ago we didn't review them
i'm really sorry about that but because
like i said we had a pile and we watched
some of them and then some of them got
misplaced or put back or something and
then we moved and we moved everything
got rearranged i'm going through that
through that big pile though and seeing
ones like i don't remember seeing this
and i'm pulling them out yeah so we have
like another pile we're going where we
keep going through there and like
picking out the ones so this was one
that we got sent a very long time ago i
think louis sent it but i'm not entirely
positive i'm like 90 positive and it was
a long time ago and i was like oh yeah
i've been wanting to see that and then
like we never got around to watching it
but i finally watched it last night and
this was actually a pretty [ __ ]
decent movie i thought it was solid but
it's not my kind of movie it's a little
serious kind of yeah it's a mystery they
call it a neo-noir which i guess it kind
of is
this was actually the directorial debut
the feature length directorial debut of
mr ben affleck
uh so this came out in 2007 so it's a
little bit older than i thought it was
because i couldn't remember when what
year this was and i was like oh this
must be 2000's when i saw everybody's
cell phones cell phones had antennas on
them yeah that's well i don't know if
they had intense but they stole flip
phones flip phones ahead and no they had
little antennas oh did they i didn't
notice that yeah so yeah so it's 2007.
so this is based on a novel which was a
big bestseller i think by dennis lehane
dennis lehane also wrote mystic river
which was also made into a movie i think
clint eastwood directed that one i
haven't seen it i think it won a bunch
of oscars even though i think in
hindsight a lot of people didn't really
like it this one um got a lot of praise
and it got one oscar nomination amy ryan
who played kind of the dirtbag mom she
got uh nominated for best supporting
actress for this and rightfully so but
yeah i mean ben affleck i kind of feel
like this was a really solid
uh directorial debut it's not visually
like a lot to look at it's pretty
workman like in that regard but i think
he got a lot out of the actors and i
think that
he did a really good job
distilling he got a really good sense of
place i mean both him and casey affleck
his brother who stars in this movie um
are from boston they're kind of from
this area they're very familiar with
this
uh environment yeah i lived there they
got the accents down and they're really
well that's because most of the people
in this movie are are from there yeah uh
pretty much all the background actors
like the people in the bars that they
talk to and stuff are locals yeah that
they got to be in the movie because he
wanted that sort of like true to life uh
type of [ __ ]
so
uh i don't know this okay so this movie
came out in 2007 so i'm not entirely
sure if i want to spoil it but then the
thing about it is that
you can't really you kind of have to
spoil it a little bit
to talk about the moral quandary that's
kind of at the heart of this movie which
i think is the thing that makes it the
most interesting and as i said i think
this is a really interesting movie for
him to start with because this is one
that
really kind of leaves you it's one of
those movies like at the end it kind of
leaves you with oh [ __ ] like what would
i do in that situation and it's really
realistic in the sense of
sort of like the the child welfare
system in the united states and like how
it's you know not the greatest but it's
sort of like what are you gonna do like
damned if you do damage you know what
it's like kind of shitty on both ends
and it also kind of explores
sort of things between what's morally
correct what's legally correct you know
what i mean so it's so it kind of
explores that gray area and i and it
doesn't really give you any easy answers
which i think is like pretty ballsy for
like his first movie to do i'm not sure
i haven't read the book so i don't know
how similar to the book this is i know
that ben affleck and like one other guy
like did the screenplay from this and i
know they made some changes but i'm not
sure how significant the changes were so
if anybody's read the book um let me
know about that
but so i don't know i kind of feel like
we'll have to spoil it a little bit just
to talk about you know what the kind of
question is at the center of it
so the the weird thing about this movie
because i didn't really know hardly
anything like i said i didn't read the
book i kind of knew that it was like a
mystery about a missing child that's
pretty much all i knew about it going in
so i didn't anticipate all the twists
and turns that this takes you know what
i mean i had no idea like where it was
going and i think that's like a better
way to go into it yeah kelly g says amy
ryan was awesome in that movie she
absolutely was i actually i know i've
seen her in other things although i
can't really place her but
she was just like such
uh
she was just like such a [ __ ]
horrible horrible person she's like
she's kind of like sympathetic i guess
but she's just like such a dirt bag that
it's like really really hard to like
sympathize with her even though her kid
gets kidnapped it's just like i don't
know that maybe that's the main thing to
say
but yeah so apparently this book too i
guess
the book the two characters at the heart
of this who are named patrick and um
angie and they're kind of like
they're sort of like pis but they don't
usually do this type of missing kid
thing they usually track down people
they're like they do like skip traces
and stuff or like people that uh you
know owe people money and take off or
you know [ __ ] like that so this is kind
of like a case that they take on but
there's more books about them i think
this might be the second or third one in
the series maybe the fifth one but
there's like several books that the same
that that writer wrote about these two
characters
so so they're like pis
and
there's this little girl she's four and
her name is amanda
and she gets abducted out of her
apartment
she lives there with her single mother
now the story is that the single mother
oh i was just across the street at my
friend's house watching tv for an hour
after i put my little kid to bed and
somebody came in the house and took her
well that's yeah that's what the story
is so like you know the media comes and
everybody's like oh my god this little
girl and she's gone and everything like
that and everybody's like sympathetic
toward the mom
but um
the the little girl's aunt and uncle who
live in the same apartment they live
like upstairs from the mom they're like
okay well we don't think the cops are
you know doing their job quick enough
because it's already been like two or
three days and they're like the kids may
be dead by now or we don't know where
she is so they're like we don't think
the cops are doing that well so you guys
are pis you live in this neighborhood
you know people around here you know a
lot of criminals and we think that maybe
uh it would be better for you like you
could find out some information that
maybe the cops wouldn't be able to find
out because they're not as familiar with
the people in this neighborhood
so they hire the two of them
patrick and angie
and
pretty soon they
find out some [ __ ] that the cops were
not able to find out because they know
all these people in the neighborhood the
first thing they find out is that no the
mom absolutely was not like across the
street uh watching tv when the girl got
kidnapped she was actually at the bar as
she was pretty much every night because
she was an alcoholic and she was doing
coke with this other
uh dirt bag like her boyfriend in the
bathroom so they were just like they're
like [ __ ] doing lines of coke for
hours and hours and then the little girl
got kidnapped what they find out later
on after that too is that the little
girl was maybe they kind of think maybe
like the cops at first think oh there's
this child molester that just got out of
prison or something like that and he
just like moved to the area so they
think maybe he might be involved but
they're like well he usually likes
little boys not little girls but we're
keeping him on the radar but one thing
that patrick and angie find out is that
uh the mom helene of the little girl
had stolen a [ __ ] ton of money from this
drug dealer like a haitian named cheese
that's not his real name but obviously
um
that's his gags today yeah which not
super intimidating but jesus is funny
though i like yeah i did actually like
cheese i mean he's a terrible he's a
criminal obviously but he was a good
character he was only in like one or two
scenes but yeah he was a good character
he saw himself as sophisticated and
enlightened
i suppose so yeah but uh yeah so they
find out that she stole a bunch of money
from him so they surmise
that cheese had the little girl
kidnapped as essentially ransom to get
the money back
so a whole kind of thing ensues and
really i was like watching the movie and
at the point where they're like okay the
because he at first says no i don't have
the kid i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
and then later on he uh he calls the
police and say no i do have the kid
we're gonna do an exchange
and then they do an exchange i'm like
wow this is happening already it's like
this this is a really short movie you
know what i mean because i was like wow
i thought this movie was like two hours
long and i was like it went by really
fast
but
the thing about it is like they do the
exchange and it goes away
and you think that
like i said okay i'm gonna i'm just
gonna spoil it you think that the little
girl gets killed you're led to believe
that the little girl dies uh by falling
into the quarry like either she gets
killed like during the in the crossfire
or she falls in or whatever so you're
kind of led to believe that she dies
and that she's had her cheese gets
killed during the fight all this other
kind of [ __ ] ensues and you think that's
like the end of the story [ __ ] the
little girl's dead they have a funeral
everything like that
but then it comes to light that there is
way more to this [ __ ] plot going on
than you think because patrick finds out
later on when he's talking to like
somebody else that
um or he's talking to ed harris who's
actually fantastic in this i'm surprised
he didn't get a [ __ ] nomination for
this he's one of the cops that's like
working with the pis
and he says something kind of like
offhand one time when he's kind of drunk
that makes patrick go hmm he told me
some other [ __ ] earlier on so he
stretched or put together maybe remy
that cop like knows more about this
[ __ ] plot than uh then he let on at
first because he lied about some [ __ ] so
he basically finds out that
the cops knew about the money being
stolen before the drug dealer actually
knew about it and the cops were actually
kind of involved in this whole exchange
situation and it was like a setup
and it turns out that the little girl is
actually still alive
now where the moral quandary comes into
it there's kind of a subplot too which
i'll get to in a second
where the moral quandary kind of comes
to is that the little girl is still
alive but the little girl is living with
morgan freeman like not actual morgan
freeman but morgan freeman's character
who is who is a retired cop
because they thought that her mom was
such a scumbag
that she would the little girl would be
better off
with a loving family because morgan
freeman's character in this he was like
the chief of police or whatever uh he
had had a child murdered like many years
ago so he kind of like knew the pain of
that he didn't have a child murdered a
child of his god a child of his got
murdered yeah yeah that sounded weird
yeah
have that child murdered
yeah i worded that badly
thank you for catching that again right
but
yes
morgan freeman has child murdered
the [ __ ] friend
yeah he had his 12 year old daughter um
you know she got murdered he didn't do
it obviously somebody else did it
uh so he had you know so they basically
concocted this big plot like to take the
little girl away and make the mom think
she was dead because the mom was such a
dirt bag um she was a drunk she was a
drug addict she was a drug mule she was
just like all around she was just
all-around [ __ ] bag i mean she was just
kind of like a shitty white trash person
and so they thought she would be better
off now the interesting moral
conundrum that this brings up is that
patrick
the one of the pis
he actually believes he's like look this
is like all the [ __ ] you did like all of
this
you know rigmarole that you went through
this whole conspiracy
you know
whether or not she was better with you
or whether that's her mom and it's like
you don't really have any right
to take her away from her mom like if
you really thought she was in danger why
didn't you go through the proper
channels why didn't you go through child
protective services why didn't you do
that
and
so there's that but then his girlfriend
interestingly is like you know why don't
you just leave a little girl with them
it's like they obviously love her they
have the money they have the resources
you know to raise her and it's like
what's gonna happen if you take her back
to her scumbag mom and you know it's
just she's just hanging out with a bunch
of [ __ ] drug dealers
yeah and that's the thing and it's just
like i like that the movie just kind of
like leaves it
ambiguous because honestly like they
give the kid back to the mom but then at
the end like the little girl seems okay
but like the mom's like oh by going out
on a date like oh yeah i guess i need a
babysitter you know what i mean so they
kind of leave it
to a thing where
yeah you kind of feel like
probably
the moral of the story is that sometimes
doing the right thing is actually the
wrong thing to [ __ ] do that's what
the story was actually meant
yeah he should have never done that
i mean i get where he was coming from he
was took a big step down going back to
where she came from all right [ __ ]
that guy was a chief of police he was
saving the kid
had he gone through the proper routes he
probably never would have been able to
get the kid anyway and it just would
have ended up in the hands of somebody
else who couldn't take care of and they
wanted the kid yeah he stole the baby we
stole the baby from a bunch of people
that would have ruined it you know i
mean yeah i'm kind of leaning toward
yeah i mean i get where he's coming from
like he was just kind of like hey this
is the right way to do things and you
didn't have any right which
yeah you could say you didn't they
didn't really have any right to take
that girl's that that woman's baby that
was her that was her kid right had
nothing to do with it but
when you kind of saw like the [ __ ] i was
kind of like yeah so i like that this
kind of brought up this whole conundrum
of like this is actually what the child
welfare system is like it's this
complicated um you know there aren't any
easy solutions it's like sometimes there
aren't any good solutions
just like in this case societies will
have these mechanisms by which try to
control this you know what i mean to try
to control the chaos
it kind of works i mean you just can't
have a world where people just go around
stealing each other's kids either
yeah that's what i'm saying because you
know if you want to go that way you
could be like well why don't they just
do that to all the kids that everybody
will have their kids taken away and i
don't think that should you might be
opening a door that you don't want to
try to have it the other way
that's why they have it this way yeah
you know what i mean that there's a
system
but
look man super rich and powerful people
[ __ ] can pay to break those systems
and do whatever they want
really that chief of police is just
doing what people richer than him do
all right because they're
responsible enough and intelligent
enough to make a good decision all right
it's not like it's just some crackheads
decided to steal a baby
it's people who [ __ ] were
professionals
they're like we can't let that baby
[ __ ] be with that family or go to the
system and [ __ ] them up we'll take
it if we raise it as our own yeah it's
not like they're gonna take it and sell
it
you know yeah or or something like that
is you know
which when you think about it that was a
traditional adoption i mean that's that
would have happened [ __ ] hundreds of
years ago
if you just saw some peasant
beating up on some child and you're a
lord or a lady just give me that kid
they'd just take it what are you even
doing yeah they would just take it and
they just raise it as their own
you know they would sometimes they did
that or they'd bring it in the house and
raise it as house staff and keep it out
of the damn
ghetto where it came from
somewhere up in [ __ ] ireland or
something you know they just did [ __ ]
like that
so really what he did is no different
than what was done over the past
thousands of years yeah like you said
it's just kind of like
yeah we do have a system in place so
for that reason because like you said we
can't just go around having people
snatching other people's kids
willy-nilly because obviously that's
going to lead to really really terrible
outcomes most of the time yeah exactly
because people will be snatching them
for all kind of like nefarious reasons
right but like i said the caveat is is
that in societies always have elites
that can make those decisions and do
make those decisions they have the money
to do to make those decisions and not
all of them good people
okay but no they got people that are
just by a kid
you know well yeah it's all illegal and
[ __ ]
but they're probably buying it from
human human services anyway imagine that
i mean [ __ ] the
we've we've done stories here on the
show where it turned out was it back in
the 70s where
parts of the catholic church were
selling and pimping out
wayward schoolgirls to the police
yeah i gotta re-watch that duck yeah i
mean there's been some weird [ __ ] that's
happened you know what i mean so in this
case this if yes me the police chief did
the right thing you know
like well i need a kid and [ __ ] i'll
raise this one good you know
yeah because i mean they'd heard about
it from and like i said yeah you can say
i i do like the way they portrayed the
mom though because she seems
very much i mean she's just a disgusting
person she's like a drunk she's a drug
addict she's like ah [ __ ] you
she's like she's very very like white
trash
um and obviously she didn't really give
that much of a [ __ ] about the kid
because she's just like leaving the kid
by herself in the house apparently like
well i mean yes her sister and
brother-in-law lived upstairs and i
presume they watched her but you know
she just didn't really seem to like care
that much she would go to the bar
there's a lot of gray in this world yeah
that's that and i like that this movie
kind of explores that because there's a
little bit of a thing like a i don't i
wouldn't even call it a side plot
because it's sort of like related but
remember when i said earlier that there
was like this child molester that
initially they thought had kidnapped the
little girl or like that's what the cops
were thinking and he was living in this
neighborhood and there's a thing where
it comes out later where a little boy
goes missing
and they figure out that this child
molester that they were thinking for the
other crime uh did it and so they bust
into that guy's house and they find out
that he's killed the little boy at which
point patrick the pi he just goes in
there sees the guy in the bathroom and
he's like i'm sorry i'm sorry like it
was an accident he says he killed the
little boy and patrick just shoots him
in the head just like executes him
pretty much
and everyone in an accident either there
was one obviously
yeah obviously so he just like looks at
him and just shoots him in the head but
then he starts to feel bad about it
later because he's like that's
straight-up murder but everybody else in
the world was just kind of like yeah you
did good i mean what the [ __ ] that dude
wasn't contributing anything so the fact
that patrick like you could tell that he
was a very like upright he always wanted
to do the right thing but
his i don't know i i feel like the fact
that he even felt bad about shooting a
[ __ ] disgusting child molester and
murderer
you know yeah you killed him in cold
blood yeah that's murder but who the
[ __ ] gonna miss that guy nobody the
movie's trying to press the boundaries
on [ __ ] what rule of law is about
yeah exactly our civilization is run by
these institutions that are going by
these set rules
that's kind of the default setting all
right but it's like a sledgehammer you
know i mean it can make mistakes and it
kind of does its job but maybe not
really and
so that's what the movie's about movies
trying to straighten your credibility
saying you know what i mean you straight
you know yeah it's trying to push the
boundaries of these things that you know
it could happen another way
but really the gray that these people
were doing
could have only really kind of happened
in a situation where you had that system
in the background running if those
systems weren't there it'd be all out
chaos just everywhere it'd be even worse
yeah so i think the systems kind of keep
kind of put some kind of order to the
chaos
but like i said
there's always people elites or people
that know better or people that are
boots on the ground that can get in
there and kind of [ __ ]
push things in the direction to make
more sense because institutions don't
make any sense if you're ever in the
army like i was you said the army is
just big and dumb
you know it kind of works
but not really most of it's just what we
did
on the ground we got we forced it to
work but you know you can only be in so
many places at once
you know well the thing about it and the
things that you feel yeah the thing
that's kind of going wrong around this
is that one you know humans and life in
general are complicated so yes we need
systems in place but obviously systems
by their very nature because everything
is complicated they're not going to be
one size fits all and there's always
going to be cases that fall between the
cracks or there's always going to be
things where it's like gray area where
there's really no good solution and you
kind of have to hammer something out so
you can't use the same
rules for everything like i said you
have to look at everything on a
case-by-case basis so i like that they
went into that with because i feel like
the thing where he shot the child
molester was a lot more cut and dried
even though he felt bad about it
afterward
but
the thing about the little girl being
taken
you know was a lot more
ambiguous i mean it's not as ambiguous
you might think because i was kind of
like yeah you should probably like leave
her with morgan freeman because yeah i
don't think that was ambiguous i think
shooting the shooting the guy who
murdered the kid was more ambiguous
because by rights he should have
he should have stood trial
you know what i mean
you can't just be judge jury and
executioner on somebody even though you
can you can do it yeah you can get a lot
of trouble though yeah
i'm just saying in that situation i
don't think anyone's gonna convict you
but you shouldn't have done it you know
what i mean yeah he did feel bad about
it he said he was ashamed that he had
done it it wouldn't have been murder
they would have said it was probably
something like like uh mass slaughter
that yeah
lacked calm reasoning and cool
reflection yeah once he saw like the
dead [ __ ] kid it got him from
manslaughter so it wasn't really murder
um but he shouldn't have done it but i
understand why he did it yeah i do too i
probably honestly attempted maybe i
would have done it i probably would have
done the same thing
i'm not gonna lie and i think a lot of
people would yeah when you saw the scene
you saw a little dead boy there you and
he said why didn't you man [ __ ] you bear
you know that yeah like i said i i kind
of feel like a lot of people would have
done that and i'm not gonna blame them
one one little bit laugh would say it
was manslaughter though that's just i
know
that's what i'm saying but i don't know
i kind of feel like i don't know it
could go either way depending on what
what jury you got but i think like i
said it's
yeah it's it's more ambiguous in that
way but it's just kind of like one
they i mean they straight up kidnapped
that kid
right i mean they kidnapped her and made
the mom think that she was not only had
been kidnapped but made her think that
the kid was dead they did a funeral and
everything yeah they set it up where it
seemed like she had fallen into the
quarry and they never found the body and
blah blah so
you know the mom was really and honestly
like the mom before they before the
exchange [ __ ] happened
you know the mom actually was more
sympathetic she was i mean she was
crying she's like promise me you'll find
him promise me you'll find her and it's
like i promise i'll never do drugs again
like if you find her and all this other
kind of stuff which maybe she wouldn't
have you know what i mean it's like you
don't know how it's gonna go
but to be honest if i i don't know it's
hard for me to say if i was in that
situation i feel like everybody's
probably had this discussion that's
watched this movie if i was in that
situation
like you know casey affleck's
dude in this movie
i feel like i would have gone with the
girlfriend i'd have been like let's just
leave her there yeah i'd have left her
there i would have just left her there
because she was already in a good home
i mean
child protective services couldn't have
put her in a better place
and the thing about it is that you know
you call the cops and then you know what
if she goes back to with her mom and
like her mom goes and od's somewhere and
the little girl starves to death or what
if you know what if somebody comes and
shoots up the place and the little girl
gets killed it's like it seems like
there's more that could go wrong
with the mom than with the other family
i mean you never know what shit's gonna
happen but
so like i'm saying even though it was
like it left her there yeah i mean even
though it was illegal yeah it was
kidnapping and they made her made her
the mom think she was dead i kind of
would have been tempted to leave the
other girl
she would have went up she would ended
up in child protective services and had
a place to do with a mediocre family
that's what happened yeah or or she
might not have gotten adopted at all
although she was like a cute little
white girl so probably she would have
but she'd ended up in a mediocre house
with a bunch of other ones like that
professional adopters basically they
have this
what do they call them
like foster like a foster family and
then um it should have been you know but
now man why would you
why wouldn't you just let her stay with
chief of police and in a damn
great family and go to university and
you know have you know not even know
that you know you were adopted yeah
because it's just
no nah yeah i do kind of feel like i
probably would have been tempted like
like i said i got why
he was like you know it's the right
thing to do because what you dudes did
was illegal
um
but i'm not gonna lie i would have been
tempted to just leave the little girl
there i think the dude is a chump if you
ask me
[Laughter]
chumpy chump
well everybody else in the movie agreed
with you i mean everybody was like what
the [ __ ] man yeah he's jumped seriously
i know they did a lot of bad [ __ ] like
everybody like that was involved in the
conspiracy even the cops like remy and
[ __ ] like that but
yeah i think for the sake of it the
little girl i think she should have
stayed at that in their house but yeah i
but i like how they kind of just left it
so it's like could go either way we
don't know just like real life so you
know yeah this was actually like a
really good movie i was like really
involved and as i said it had so many
twists and turns that i was not
expecting i basically thought this was
like a missing kid movie and it is but
then when you get to the one part where
they're doing the exchange and then it
goes off on this other like conspiracy
direction and i thought that was kind of
cool like i wasn't really expecting it
um and as i said i really really like
you don't really see
uh depictions of like the white working
class
in boston you don't really see that in
movies a lot like because these are some
scumbags in this [ __ ] movie like um i
mean the mom is
one of the better ones like when they're
doing the investigation and like they're
going around like all these bars like
everybody is a [ __ ] dirt bag you know
what i mean and it's just
i don't know it's just like really
really funny and honestly the
i don't know if this is from the book or
this was from ben affleck's screenplay
but like the first part of the movie
where he's going around like
investigating and he's talking to all
the locals and stuff
some of the dialogue in there is [ __ ]
hilarious like everything is just i mean
they swear like a [ __ ] blue streak
but just the [ __ ] they say is just so so
[ __ ] funny yeah i lived there for
about six years in boston
well one of the suburbs of boston most
of it is somerville medford that area
this was set in uh dorchester dorchester
yeah i've never been over there but i
know where they're talking about
um this is in the 90s
it costs a lot of money to live there uh
but they they they make pretty good
money if you're not in some kind of
union or something
filled with a bunch of college students
too
but i know i had fun there it's all
right um
but yeah it's
it's not like new york at all i kind of
like new york in a certain way a little
bit better i think people a little
tougher although
what you're talking about you know like
the
north end and the east end you know the
italian guys and the irish yeah this was
mostly boston irish yeah they're they're
uh they're they're pretty i guess you
say pretty tough you know
uh it's in a certain way they had their
own this it's it's an urban kind of
thing you know
but um
yeah that was that's that's pretty much
how they sound just like that i mean
that's them
that's them yeah i mean they like i said
they got a bunch of locals to be yeah
and ben affleck and casey affleck are
both from that area boston is the
american interpretation of london really
it's it's it's a city that kind of looks
like london it's
when it was when it was colonial it was
built to look like it
um there's a lot of the
all the names are british sounded you
know um
yeah
you'd run into europeans you know they'd
come over and visit and they think they
would they thought that all of america
was like that and i'd have to go nah
this is boston and boston is like
something out of something out of you
know something out of england
you know
the rest of the united states doesn't
like that you know yeah like you know i
had to convince these damn german girls
that
subways weren't everywhere and that you
couldn't take a subway from boston to
mississippi
you know
no
there's no subways there we have public
transit all of it has because there's no
concept of how sparsely populated a lot
of america i mean new england all up
there yeah they have trains up there you
can see where you can go from place to
place but
not down here you don't know we got
trains but they go from we got amtrak
and we got sun rail which goes just
around orlando and the outskirts and
that's about you might have something
and nobody rides yeah nobody
it's not the population isn't dense
enough you know new england is old it's
much older than the rest of the united
states
because it's spread out in that
direction but uh no like there isn't
even hardly anything that i would call
a forest or anything in new england i
mean yeah maybe there is but they're
small compared to what you'd have here
you know people don't get it i mean you
know well i mean down here texas is
twice the size
of [ __ ] germany texas yes yeah just
texas twice the size of germany well and
i've told people before like from the uk
when they came here i was like look i
can drive for five hours and still be in
florida yeah
so
yeah
you know you know people like well you
know [ __ ] in the europeans are also
upset about guns and [ __ ] same thing up
in new england area they're upset about
gods well they have police protection
here man or place in mississippi police
response time might be an hour and a
half
i mean
depending on how rural you live yeah
yeah maybe none at all you're on your
own
yeah well the thing about places like
florida and stuff like that is that you
know cities are so far apart and even
within cities
it's not yeah like orlando and tampa and
stuff like they have a downtown but
there's so much stuff that's out in the
suburbs and so many people live out in
the suburbs that
there's really no reason i mean you
really need a car yeah there's just
really no way to get around
in florida without one
that uh there are places in mississippi
and louisiana where uh and also alabama
where there are houses on dirt roads
and those roads don't have any names
no names just numbers
yeah it'll be like 42-105.
there's no name what are you doing and
they don't even have mail service
you have to go to the post office to get
their mail
god that's going to be a pain in there
yeah yeah i've seen some places like
that and it might be you know 20 mi 20
minute drive to go to the post office
good pokey what are you doing she's
tearing my notebook and you'd think it
would be like a damn
shack or something you'd see in the
movies but no it'd be a normal house
normal looking house
um you know like something you'd see in
the neighborhood around here a recent
construction too
it's just almost basically totally off
the grid although they did have electric
power
it's just weird you know no internet
though probably they'd probably have it
now
probably have hughes net
yeah something like that yeah yeah good
luck with that
yeah if you have a hurricane like it
knocks it out yeah it's pretty good for
that as long as you don't have to do
anything within you know oh man
that elon bus sky lake what are they
calling it that's going to be great
starlight i think is that up yet
i don't think it's up here
it's going to be like
wireless internet high speed for
everybody i don't think it's free though
i don't know maybe it is probably not
huh i don't know what are you asking me
for
satellites
kelly says uh talk about the movie now
it will become a cycle of neglect and
abuse because she was returned to the
drug addicted mother who obviously
didn't change so whatever yeah i'm kind
of thinking it probably would have been
better for the kid to just like yeah it
was a chumpy solution he would leave her
where she was yes i know like i said he
was trying to do the right thing but
sometimes the right thing isn't the
right thing sometimes the right thing is
the wrong thing
yeah it's the legal thing but
in that case probably not the best thing
for the kid uh yeah so i probably would
have i was kind of like the whole time
i'm like why don't you just listen to
your girlfriend like just leave she was
already placed in the best house she
could be in yeah i mean they actually
wanted her yeah and if child protective
services was would was working she
wouldn't have been with that family
anyway the the drug family
yeah they would have taken they would
have taken it anyway but i guess since
everybody in that neighborhood was such
a dirt bag like nobody reported her
because it was just kind of like well
yeah she's more dirt baggy than me yeah
that's not good i know but exactly
that's what i'm saying that's why she
didn't get reported like in a normal in
normal circumstances she would have been
reported and the kid would have been
taken away and rightfully so i think
that there's good i mean some people
just should not be parents obviously um
and there should be mechanisms for
taking kids away from those people that
you shouldn't just be able to go in and
snatch people there's just so many
willy-nilly but
you know yeah just so many of them what
you gonna do with them you know that's
why that's why they do that you know
what i mean yeah that's true they're
just so many of them it's true but yeah
uh this was actually a really good movie
i've been wanting to see it for a really
long time and uh so i'm finally glad i
finally got around to it so if it was
you that sent it louis thank you very
much for sending it if it wasn't thank
you whoever it was because it was a long
time ago and i'm glad i finally got
around to it so sorry it took so long
but uh yeah so that'll do it for today i
guess so tomorrow night's the main show
and guess what we're doing tomorrow
night we're going to talk about some
happy little trees we're going to talk
about bob [ __ ] ross no relation
i don't think bob ross how was that
paranormal or nonself just some people
wanted that because people asked me
that's what they wanted they said oh you
should do a show about bob ross because
he's like really interesting i think it
was like a couple weeks ago we were
talking about something else and
somebody said oh you should do a show
about bob ross you well you said
yesterday that sounds like a fun show
when i told you he forgets what i he
forgets what he said today but yeah i
think it'll be interesting that we'll do
it if not i think it'll be
we'll get drunk and do a painting a goof
on it we should we should oh my god we
should do a painting like while we're on
this show
i've got some paint that i used to do
i'll put a piece of paper back there
we'll do some happy little treats
that'll be [ __ ] funny
it's too bad you don't have a bob ross
wig you need an aphrodisiac do you have
an afro no [ __ ]
oh well no we should have planned better
for this oh well all right so uh we'll
see you guys again uh tomorrow evening
thanks for dropping by